we've made it to the finale of the bad
batch people excited to be here for it
watch the wrap-up to this what's this
one called camino loss yeah no kidding i
want to thank everyone who's uh been
tuning in to our reactions for this
since the first episode uh it's been a
pleasure it's been a hell of a ride in
the meantime guys if you enjoy our
reaction please go ahead and hit that
like button as always full length watch
along so we stick with the time code
over at our patreon cover a bunch of
shows over there as well also thank you
to bertham or jaden whoever edited this
video appreciate you editing this
highlights down for us buddy let's watch
this finale and see what goes on what's
gonna become of crosshair
a whole lot to unpack here let's get
into it
[Music]
damn it omega
oh brother
all
kaminoan facilities have
collapsed into the sea
man rendezvous with the fleet
even he seems bummed out about it
[Music]
makes sense is it close this is where
they were created yeah this is their
birthplace one of the few remaining
clone troopers
i do not wish to alarm you but if you do
not vacate this compartment you will
soon perish and i will be left here on
my own
we don't want that cross hand
he's going to have amnesia
remember anything the room is flooding
and crossing stuck
get the door open i cannot override the
protocols from here i can
greetings 9904
oh
[Music]
get off what the hell is
[Music]
oh
where's easy
okay all right
catch him we need to get topside before
this entire structure submerges
if you want to stay here and die
that's your call
this better be the fattest wake-up call
for you dude
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
i love that little guy
[Music]
it's so harrowing
[Music]
what the [ __ ] okay
follow me
[Music]
kiddo come on cross hair move
i'll follow you but i'm not i'm not
coming with you
they're all going to die here because of
your failed leadership
no we're not
look
we landed on the underwater tunnel
yeah well
great super easy
accessing the tube would be
challenging
we have to try you're up to a tech he's
calling the shots now you have a better
idea
ouch you didn't have to do that
the tunnel is clear
yippee
i mean at least as much of it as you can
see from here
we need to go back
are you done complaining
you know if it wasn't for you we
wouldn't be in this mess
all that time
you didn't even try to come back we
still would have taken you
oh
crosshair has always been severe and
unyielding
[Laughter]
let's keep moving
i think we got a problem sure
right only when the power is operational
which it is not
and when the glass isn't all cracked
maybe yeah you should just ran to begin
with
restoring power should you turn the
creature try to stay alive
[Music]
scared yeah just the scope alone
oh you clever
[Music]
monster oh
it appears i have caused this
structure's remaining power to short out
but you have survived the transit this
outcome is satisfactory
[Laughter]
thanks say z what is this
private lab
omega says this is where our mutations
were manipulated and enhanced how would
she now
omega was created before us
technically she is older than we are
she remains a child huh she's like the
reverse of most clones she is super slow
that's gonna be a problem
it would seem that once again we are
trapped
i see
what's wrong my battery cells are
depleting
this is what happens when you let a kid
call the shot you shut up and look
around you this whole time the empire
will control the entire galaxy and i
am going to be a part of it
then you should help them get out of
here alive
all you'll ever be to them is a number
you never liked it on camino did you
go away
i spent most of my life in this lab
i was alone down here
until you four were created
being a clone doesn't make you one of
them
i wanted to believe it was the inhibitor
chip
that made you like this but
i was wrong
you're just an [ __ ] these medical
capsules are our way out of here we
won't have directional control how do we
avoid the debris field out there let's
try it
izzy
can you guide us to the surface barring
any extraneous complications i should be
able to complete the task won't that be
dangerous
your safety and well-being is my primary
mission objective
no
i have accessed my reserve power we must
hurry
he's barely got the explosives are sick
i'm not gonna make it
they're in the same tube that's been
meant by double up okay
[Music]
ask to ask crush crutch
in a lover's embrace
[Music]
wow
that is scary
[Music]
damn dude you're kicking ass mvp
of the mission
you're doing great
lazy no
no
[Laughter]
i'm so worried for him
i think omega will be fine
more reserve power
oh
[ __ ]
don't give up we're nearly there oh
no
your path is
oh boy i don't see it
come on omega
i'm going in
i'll cover you
[Music]
what a messed up mislead cross hair i'm
gonna ate this head hunter for a second
but you
[Music]
armed himself
i have a visual on the marauder
i suggest we start paddling
well you kind of forget that there's
daylight
what a beautiful day
oh crap
that's so so emotional
[Music]
it's
all gone
[Music]
we should leave before the empire's
scouts show up
are you coming with us
none of this changes anything
you offered us a chance crosshair
this is yours
i made my decision
drop me off at the empire
different things
that doesn't mean that we have to be
enemies
i mean
you would
in this case
i think you're fine
what thank you for saving a z
consider us even
you're still their brother across here
you're my brother oh
man is so sad
my little brother
[Music]
don't let them see you cry don't let
them see you cry
galaxy uber
[Laughter]
uber galaxy
um
okay
let's get some answers
get to work on making that palpatine
mistress nyla say
welcome we are all admirers of your
scientific talents the empire has big
things planned for you
[Music]
it was the same
similar outfits to what they were the
scientists were wearing and mad lauren
i feel like kinda yeah
i'd have to go back and like really
examine them but
[Music]
we get to work on making those clones
kudos to d bradley baker michelle egg
man
z the true champion of this episode
right here
that uh that was i got all emotional i
kept setting him up to die yeah
do a puppy killing right at the end
there just kept setting him up i'm like
you better not do it
you better not actually kill that little
droid off man you bring a lot of tension
out
[Laughter]
that was great this is a great little
final you know just mood stamper on
everything like you know
these past two episodes really do feel
like one big
sort of arc and i've seen some people
complain about you know the fact they
split it up but i don't know i thought
this made for a really gripping sort of
end note for the season
people were complaining
i've seen i don't know i've just in the
passing this morning i saw some people
be like oh this should have been an
hour-long finale instead of you know
breaking it into two episodes but i
don't know i guess it's a stray idea i
saw i don't share the opinion
necessarily
oh yeah i don't i could do either or
with it yeah i don't think it really
needs to be
separate or it needs to be together i
think it was fine uh having it i think
the expectation that is set up from the
last one is that this might be a little
bit more of like a pulse pounder of an
episode where this was a little bit more
somber and uh like
the considering the circumstances that
they're in you know they they dealt with
the environment that they're thrusted
into which is you can't really do much
you know
the the
they did wring out a lot of tension
during
especially in the later half of the
whole tube sequence like i loved when uh
i mean i loved everything with az
especially i didn't like i love the
bookend too
not really a bookend
but
like wow they get even with omega saving
crosshair and then crosshair helping to
save omega
uh near the end of this episode but yeah
when they had to go through like the
whatever
i wanted to say tubes for everything
yeah because okay there's the tunnel and
the tunnel thing was like the most
convenient aspect
to the show
it's the force
it's the most how the force works it's
the most convenient aspect to it where
they just
happen to land directly on it
the mystery tunnel of the hidden tunnel
and i thought it was neat how
um
their beginnings ended up being
something that could help
keep them alive through a lot of it like
right down to where their old room was
and then when they go into their uh the
place where the lab where they were
created now lsa's uh lab and how
being in where they were birthed is the
thing that helps keep them alive it's
kind of a
it's like poetry absolutely it doesn't
rhyme but it's poetic yeah
it harmonizes
spiritually with itself in an artistic
kind of way where you're like oh wow
this almost was faded
yes it could seem
crosshairs evidently
at war with himself very conflicted i
wonder what season two will be for the
character
i appreciate that they didn't
that they didn't uh have him have a full
turn here yes yeah because this epis
because this the bad batch as much as
about a lot of things within star wars
this this group of
clones a specific group and then
uh you know like the connectivity from
transitioning between prequel to a new
hope
and uh and clone wars to rebels you know
like there's a lot that it's filling in
the gap for
i think for a season one finale it's
fitting because
the first episode um
is about the fallout between
cross i mean it's like yes on discovery
the empire but in terms of the personal
basis it's
the fallout between cross hair and the
batch
and the most gripping episodes often
are the ones that directly involve
crosshair being involved because he's
not in every episode the way the batches
or the rest of the batch
uh but the the main gripping storyline
often involved crosshair to some extent
or some degree
so to have your first episode be where
they have a fallout
where it has uh you know like there's a
debate here with crosshair i mean even
he sits down at one point and puts his
hand on his head like headache pain
thing
so i've seen the so when like when that
moment popped up but when um omega sat
next to him
i
i've heard the thing of like maybe
crosshairs lying about having the chip
removed
um
you know like with the the question of
when did he get the chip removed
was it after he
left the batch like in between was it
right before and a lot of people have
their own conclusive theories to which
they stayed as fact
but um i don't know i i prefer that they
keep it that he made a choice it makes
it more compelling
but yeah editing off on this note of you
know
because they had that line that
echo uh no tech says
to crosshair of like i
understand you doesn't mean i agree with
you
and they kind of end off on that note
when they leave crosshair there
stranded no way to get out was there a
way for him to get out did i miss a ship
no but he seemed very calm so i'm sure
he's got a
an escape hatch or something yeah he'll
shoot a shoot a plane down the empire's
down to leave him with that oh [ __ ] dude
what are you doing here again come on
let's get you out of here before we
destroy more of camino do they even
leave him with a gun
no because he tossed his gun to wrecker
i think yeah in the boat yeah he did but
they could have given it back to him
yeah they could have what if he gets
hungry
he can eat the gun shoot if you know you
can shoot a fish or something right this
guy he could shoot that big shoot that
big thing yeah i just can't get out of
that living you know repurpose the bones
and make a little shack on that platform
there maybe season two crossfit never
got off and he's just lived as a
castaway
beard yeah
but never grew hair he goes insane and
he's like talking to himself he ever
grew head hair that's right and they
come back and he's completely different
and then he rejoins the batch because
he's insane that little helipad is just
his little island there he lives off of
yeah completely isolated in the galaxy
there's an episode i think called the
battle of camino russo camino during the
daylight and uh
i forgot that you could see camino
during the two
songs existed
yeah man and i mean it's such a such a
striking visual in an episode full of
striking visuals sure you finally yeah
the sun is out and the water is all
serene and all that and i love the
contrast because they did so much in
this with
just like the background detail of just
like the enormous falling debris out of
every window when they're you know back
in their quarters or back in the lab or
whatever and and having to you know
float up through all that like you know
this episode in a lot of ways is an
obstacle course but i thought they made
a very moody
uh uh you know
like it matched the you know
internal action them you know
desperately trying to escape but also
kind of trying to find their way out of
this moral dilemma together and yeah i i
really i hope that he
right now it seems like it's more
appropriate for him to actually have the
chip out because that seems like it's
supposed to be a pretty big revelation
and yeah it makes everything much more
hard to parse of just this is conviction
this is what's hard about real life and
i feel like you know star wars does
breach into that it's like i really like
them having that theme of like just
because i understand you doesn't mean i
agree with you and you know just because
we uh you know have different ideologies
doesn't mean we have to be enemies even
though again in this context
look at the empire it seems like it's
kind of part of the job description is
sort of being certain people's enemies
but uh yeah i i thought you know to to
use those ideas kind of separate from
the action but in harmony with the
action was nice and gripping and it's
like this
finale for the season felt more
contained than i was initially expecting
but i almost liked that it was back to
nobody else it's just the batch and it's
just the core conflict that started the
very beginning of the season and that
also is probably happening among a lot
of different tight-knit groups across
the galaxy as the empire rises up you
know well yeah it brings it back to the
character development of all them even
like
learning the fact about omega
that's the first time they i know that
was a theory was that the first time
they clarified that made it made it
abundantly clear yeah that she was made
before them
and she watched them grow
oh she is like their older sister she's
there who's treated like their younger
sister
[Laughter]
yeah but even with her like saving uh
cross hair and you know using her bow
and arrow and before prior omega might
have been too scared or timid but she's
really grown into her own
and i really
really cared about her i really care
about her a lot i love her and
this rest of the rest of the team
really solid too i can see why crosshair
doesn't see that the empire left them
behind i think
all puns intended crosshair just thought
he was caught in the crosshairs of the
fire of taking down kamino yeah and it
was just stuck there because of them
carrying out their mission and i should
have been off the planet before then
it's as simple as that yeah yeah when i
get back they're gonna welcome me and
they're gonna you know let me right back
into my you know status that i left off
at and i'm going to keep doing jobs for
the empire it's going to be great now
would nala say at the end
must be
making snokes
yeah making palps palps and snokes
continuing the specific cloning
but
they obviously don't get that far
because in the mandalorian they're
looking for grogu because he has the
right cellular dna
to do this or is groggy a clone i'm
trying to remember my facts here
now bat batch season 2 she's going to be
torturing and extracting blood from
grogu just the entire time i mean maybe
it'd be a huge time jump
yeah the clones are such a big part of
this universe and we didn't see any
wrecks i imagine he'll be back in season
two
no ahsoka imagine ahsoka will be in
season two
our favorite animated returning
characters will all be appearing in
season two
clone wars will be picked back up during
bad batch season two yeah
but uh yeah as far as a season finale
goes uh i could see how some might be a
little disappointed just due to the fact
of how it wasn't
um a high pulse pounding banger of an
episode but more of a mood piece that
focused on
the immerse emotional turmoil of the
characters not just in their physical
circumstances but also
in the separation of ideologies
uh i mean i mean everyone's on the same
page with one guy but
it was all um centered around that
too
but
yeah i thought it was a solid ending
that was a solid conclusion for season
one i mean there's more there's more to
one pack and they leave off on a
decent enough cliffhanger you know like
just because they destroy camino they
show right there we know this just from
it being star wars
that that
we're gonna explore uh fill in the gaps
of the cloning elements that have taken
place post camino and it is a harrowing
aftermath because
that is their birthplace they are
technically kaminoans all the all the
clones batch included and they are
technically kaminoans
so goodbye to their home they really
have no home now everything has yet been
rendered off the face of the planet
and that's more of omega's home than
anyone else's yeah she's actually spent
most of her life yeah yeah yeah yeah
just wanted to get off that rock yeah um
but
we'll see how it progresses
question is to you guys
did we ask it
which
star war do you want to see in season
two
got it
nailed it
guys
will
crosshair
come out next season
well i have two gay characters in star
wars i assume i come out yeah
because you know we had those that one
couple in uh
and the rise of skywalker
so
those are the closest lesbian girls
yeah
but there are extras so they count as
one together
whereas like cross hairs as an actual
character just wait till disney does two
guys oh look out
and it's it's a little ways off we've
been on board for two women for a very
long time
even straight
guys can get into that
hypocrite for that yeah yeah yeah but
not too we can't have finn and pogo it's
not acceptable
it wouldn't happen
hey
hit that like button if you enjoyed our
vid
jason dolan who couldn't give a [ __ ]
about this show
at all cazzy not reacts to the bad batch
actually wait a minute jason is he he
really loved the clone wars dude jason
so maybe he does watch this show this is
the perfect shout out it turns out oh
man i'm gonna make a bunch of jokes
about you but now and realize that
you're probably into this jason
um i hope you enjoyed the clone wars
i don't know why you're still pledged
jason's actually just one of my really
good friends and uh jason just saw him
like a week or two ago and i just talked
to them all much yesterday just like
jason's here i mean he's even catchy
shout outs jesus what are you doing here
jason
you just left auto bill on i have
friends
and then i have subscribers
and then there's patrons and there's
jason's
all right the personality i present
to patrons and subscribers
very different than who i am as a friend
as a friend i'm way nicer
way more polite
this whole
super edgy
you know
rough around the edges tough guy act
that you guys always see on display
the kind of guy who would just mess you
up at a bar that's all just the persona
that all of you have picked up on here
because in real life i'm a teddy bear
that's right but here you know i know
people are like
don't mess with greg he comes across
like he would whip your ass if you give
him the wrong look i know i have that
generally greg will kill you and that's
how i met jason
whooped his ass
and i was like sorry man i thought there
was a camera pointed at me oh should i
mean that i didn't mean that here
let me take you out to a strip club hmm
that's a good we went consolation ended
up being an all-male strip club oh
very
comfortable
for both of us
um but especially jason yeah he got a
job that day oh good yeah started as a
bartender worked his way up to the pole
dude eventually his mom came in felt
very ashamed about the whole situation
so he said i had to quit and then jason
spent a long time trying to figure out
what to do
eventually found his way back into
hookering oh good he was doing that
before stripping and so now he can
really live a fulfilling life yeah i
might just got this whole video
demonetized for the last 10 seconds
well you know it was it was worth it
because that means he'll give you a free
dance
which is at least a forty dollar value
[Music]
you